Hey everybody Sue at Knit it Now.
I thought I would jump on today and tell
you about something brand new that we just
added to the site.
We added a new classroom
knititnow.com/Swatch.
Guess what that's all about?
My favorite subject .. Swatching.
The classroom is just a compilation of
everything that we've have on the website
It's just a great place to just pull it
all together and help you find information
and really really really
encourage you to knit swatches.
You know, I've never understood why
swatching is a problem for Knitters,
especially machine Knitters.
Oh my gosh.
What does it take you 10
minutes to knit a Swatch?
Really?
There's no excuse.
And without it how do you
know how much yarn you need?
How do you know how this this yarn is
going to knit up and whether your are even
going to like it?
How do you know that this thing is going
to turn into something gorgeous and
wonderful?
You can take it on
faith or you can swatch.
Going back to washing.
Let's say you would wash this
thing and it falls apart.
How do you know until you actually try it?
I'd hate for you to knit a whole sweater
and put all that time and energy in and
number one: not like it.
Number two:.
It doesn't fit.
Number three: It shrinks.
Number four: the yarn biases
or bleeds or something.
No, make a Swatch ahead of time.
Take that 10 minutes and do it.
So, you know exactly what you're getting.
In the new classroom again,
it's knititnow.com/Swatch.
We have tips.
We've got tips about tension,
machine specific tips.
Did you know that there are a couple
of different types of swatches?
One is a tension Swatch, you know, you
get a new cone or a ball of yarn and you
really just don't know
what tension to Knit it.
Well, the best way is to
knit a tension Swatch.
Cast on and knit in p attern pattern at
maybe the tightest tension you think that
that yarn will take.
Knit for a couple of inches, loosen
up knit for a couple of inches.
Loosen up knit for a couple inches until
you get to it to a Swatch or tension
that's really loose and sloppy.
Drop the thing off the machine and you're
going to know immediately how it feels
whether you like that at
a specific tension or not.
And if it's a brand new yarn to you and
maybe is a little iffy go ahead and wash
it and treat it how you think
you're going to treat your garment.
So if there's any shrinkage that comes
up, now's the time to learn about it.
Once you determine how you're
going to knit your Swatch.
You can work a gauge Swatch.
Now a gauge swatch for machine
Knitters is just really easy.
Come on.
Don't tell me that you're
still counting stitches right?
Hand hitters.
I see them laboriously counting stitches
and Counting rows no, no, no, no, no, no
machine Knitters mark specific area.
We isolate a specific area
on our Swatch with markers.
Right and markers on the rows and you know
exactly how many stitches and rows in that
isolated area.
You measure it and you get your gauge.
No counting easy peasy.
No counting a stitches and rows.
So once you do that, You measure your
Swatch you dress it first, you know you
wash it block it whatever
you're going to do with it.
Then you get your gauge.
And from there.
You really know that your garment's going
to fit especially if you're using a Knit
it Now Dynamic pattern, you don't
have to match anybody's gauge.
Put in your gauge and generate
your own custom pattern.
So we do have lots of tips, we have tools
and by the way, we even have a course an
entire course on swatching.
That's free for subscribers
guarantee your success with swatches.
You've got practice exercises and reviews
and questions and the whole course format
to make sure that you
understand why you're swatching.
How to do it and just the importance
of knitting a gauge Swatch.
It's free for subscribers.
We're going to cement that knowledge up
here so that you have success with your
knitting.
If you have a joined us we do go live
every Tuesday 10:00 o'clock mountain time.
So I'm near Phoenix.
So Google "what time is it in Phoenix?"
So I can compare it to your time.
Ten o'clock mountain time and every
week we talk about subjects that are of
importance to machine Knitters.
Everything from swatching,
to stitch patterning to
different types of garment patterns
to software to ....  Oh my gosh!
To fit.
Everything from soup to nuts
and everything in between.
So I hope you can join us.
If the time doesn't work out for you.
We do have replays.
Our replays are up for a week can watch
the replays and we put some show notes in
and some links to the things
that we've talked about.
You can see the chat.
We like to get our Knitters involved in
the chat and just make it a little bit of
an Knit club and opportunity for you
to spend some time with other machine
Knitters, which so many of us
don't have that opportunity.
So join us at knititnow.com / live
to go to the Swatch classroom.
It's knititnow.com swatch.
And I hope you'll visit even if you're not
a believer about swatching go and visit
knititnow.com /Swatch and I'll
make a Believer out of you.
Hope to see on Tuesday or in the replay.
Happy knitting everyone.